[Music]
rideshare electric scooters if you live
in a city you've probably seen these on
the streets and while they may offer a
cheap and convenient way of getting from
a to b they've also caused some
accidents
and according to a recent study most of
those accidents happen right here
on the sidewalk see while it's illegal
to ride on the sidewalk people still do
even when they're told not to do you
know it's illegal to ride those on the
pavement so now rideshare companies like
bird and spin are trying to stop people
cruising down the sidewalk for good and
to do so they're trying to make their
scooters smarter but they're not just
developing new technology to try and
keep riders and pedestrians safe they're
also doing it to try and survive more on
that later so what are they doing well
let's find out
okay so in case you don't know here's
how these e-scooters work you download a
smartphone app and for just a few
dollars you can unlock one of these and
go zipping along at speeds of up to 15
miles per hour
let's go and while many people use them
safely and legally some don't on the
highway bro what are you doing
bro what are you doing there have been
issues with everything from drunk
driving to people not wearing helmets to
people riding in tandem but scooter
companies have managed to partially
address some of these problems through
techy solutions like using an in-app
test to try and establish if the rider
is drunk or using photo verification to
check if you're wearing a helmet or
monitoring weight distribution to stop
people riding in tandem but as simple as
it may seem trying to find a techie way
to stop people from riding this on the
sidewalk has been really challenging for
these companies and that's because this
scooter and others like it knows roughly
where i am and can stop me from going in
certain zones but it has no idea exactly
where i am and crucially it can't tell
the difference between the road and the
sidewalk and that means the only thing
that's really stopping me from riding
this over here is my executive producer
who has said i categorically cannot
break the law
especially on camera so to try and solve
sidewalk riding rideshare companies are
turning to a.i we started getting a
request from cities to say hey
we'd like you guys to be responsible for
not riding on the sidewalks bird who
were one of the first rideshare
e-scooter companies say they're testing
a chip that fuses gps data with other
sensors to get a better understanding of
exactly where the rider is the gps chip
on its own might say hey i think that
you're somewhere in this uh area and
then you can just say well hey 30 feet
ago the gps was super confident and we
know that we've traveled about 30 feet
and we haven't changed course and so in
practice we can get down to about 10
centimeters of accuracy but told me that
information is then crossed referenced
with sidewalk location data to calculate
if the rider is on the sidewalk the
sensors aren't out on their public
scooters just yet so it's yet to be seen
how effective this technology will be in
the real world but bird tells me it will
be coming out sometime this year
meanwhile tech providers like drover ai
are working on a different solution we
look around via the camera and our brain
is the ai processor on board the vehicle
that is using deep learning algorithms
that have been trained across dozens of
cities and multiple millions of images
to effectively
do granular infrastructure distinction
drover's system the path pilot uses
cameras to detect whether the scooter is
riding on the road or the sidewalk and
has already been retrofitted to some
2600 scooters most of which are operated
by spin it makes a lot of sense to
integrate this more fully into the
vehicle design that typically takes a
little time but right now no company is
using both solutions and every company
i've spoken to had a different stance on
how effective each technology would be
but you may be wondering why rideshare
companies are going to length to stop
people from riding on the sidewalk when
at the end of the day it's the rider
themselves that's breaking the law well
it's partly to do with the rideshare
company's survival see when rideshare
e-scooters first appeared on our streets
they were somewhat unregulated and that
meant that pretty much anyone could
start a rideshare company i think that
initially the vendors were more
interested in being able to put out as
many devices as they could in any
particular location and not having the
restrictions
placed on them but now some counties and
cities are beginning to drastically
limit the number of rideshare e-scooter
companies that are allowed to operate so
to try and secure that golden ticket
permit these companies are trying to
advertise to city officials that they
can be safer than their rivals can't
just be a different color than the next
operator you have to show up with the
kind of tech that cities are starting to
demand and for some getting that permit
may be the only way to turn a profit if
they know that they're one of limited
number that are licensed and able to
distribute their devices that they are
going to at least meet a particular
market share that they're hoping will be
enough for profits spin recently said it
was doing just that no longer competing
in open permit markets where anyone
could operate as the company said it was
difficult to be profitable in those
markets and with companies battling to
secure those permits experts say there
could be consolidation ahead so while
new technology may make e-scooters a
little bit safer it may also kill off
some of the competition
hey thanks for watching what forms of
micro mobility are you following let me
know in the comments below and if you're
interested in the future of how we might
be getting from a to b then don't forget
to subscribe see you soon